l'accès au vaccin spoutnik v c'est ce
que propose ce centre de vaccination
situé aux abords du stade 2 qu'il met
dans la province de buenos aires
ce sont pour l'instant les argentins
âgées de plus de 70 ans qui ont accès au
sérum alors que le pays est en pleine
deuxième vague
nous avons besoin de solidarité nous
avons besoin que chacun soit responsable
pour que cette deuxième vague que nous
traversons déjà ne se termine pas par un
effondrement du système de santé
aujourd'hui à kiel metz nous sommes
entre 60 et 70 % d'occupation des lits
de soins intermédiaires et des lits de
soins intensifs également spoutnik vers
reçoit un franc succès parmi les pays
latino américains ils sont désormais une
dizaine d'états avoir approuvé le vaccin
développé par la russie une campagne de
vaccination qui suscite l'espoir chez
les argentins qui reçoivent leur
première dose c'est ma première dose et
dans trois mois ce sera la deuxième
j'attends le vaccin parce que j'ai la
conviction que nous allons sortir de
cette crise et pour cela il faut des
choses comme la vaccination avec un peu
de chance ce sera fini après ça une
sortie de crise que les autorités
espèrent rapide à ce jour l'argentine a
enregistré environ 2 millions 300 mille
cas de kobe 19 pour près de cinquante
six mille décès